I remember seeing Vince
um
as a young kid and I tell the story
every during every interview but
um I was in the stands as a young kid my
favorite player we were in the full
purple and gold the shoes and everything
full everything you're vinced out fenced
out headband not even neat I didn't like
wearing Heavens but I wore it just
because of Vince
um
and I yelled his name as as
um
as hard as I could
and I said yes Carter
and I could tell like he's in the game
like he's in the game and
he's got this kid out of nowhere just
heckling at him and I'm just sitting
there so excited I'm asked can I yell
his name can I yell his name
and he looked up and he went like this
and I'll never forget about that I'll
remember the story remember the day just
just going like just going like that
um
so when I see a kid or I see a fan even
adults it's kind of weird with adults
because it's like you should understand
like just give me you know just take it
just chill yeah chill out we're grown
but when I see a kid at least
um with that kind of excitement like I
don't I don't I took I just drop
everything you know I don't have to
carry that with me when I see a kid
um so happy because that that moment
changed my life that moment changed my
outlook my
um perception on people
um all that stuff so just by when I was
six years old I remember that that
changed me